I was told when I started that couldn't
be a director because I was a woman
and I've been directing now for many
years but certainly not as frequently as
I would have had I been a man
I was going into meetings on projects
with people as a feature director who
had worked with Academy award-nominated
actors so I should have been taken
seriously in these meetings but I wasn't
it was always a sense of can you really
do this that a man can do it better
people would say things to me like your
movie would have gotten a bigger
distribution deal had you been a man a
lot of people have crazy prejudice that
we can't direct action movies even
though we might have grown up doing
sports our whole lives and taking all
kinds of boxing and fight classes you
can't actually look at a man and say he
probably doesn't know how to cook and
you can't look at a woman and say she
probably knows nothing about sports
we're not in the 19th century not every
woman director is capable of directing
every movie not every man director is
capable of directing every movie we all
have a different skill set to bring to
the job but the job is completely gender
neutral you ask any man who has a
wonderful career who loves what they're
doing what would happen if somebody told
you you can't do that because you have
the wrong genitals I mean it's absurd
we knew that there was something wrong
but we didn't know it was that bad but
it was that bad and so the next question
was what are we going to do about this
by the time you get into the DGA
you've long been a director you know
you're not just coming off the street
they're not recruiting new talent from
out of nowhere
sadly part of the issue for women is
that we are lumped into a category of
diversity and so the numbers dwindle
because half or even more than half of
those jobs go to men of diversity
instead of just women in the DGA studio
diversity agreements ethnic minority men
and women of all ethnicities are clumped
together in one category
so when showrunners or studio execs feel
that in order to comply with DG a studio
diversity agreements they have to hire
enough minority man or a woman
invariably
they hire a man an ethnic minority man
so I proposed that we create a double
mandate system that instead of having
one diversity program we would have to
separate diversity programs one of the
diversity programs would include women
of all ethnicities and the other group
would include ethnic minority people of
both genders in this way women of color
would qualify for both employment pools
so the studios show runners and
executives would have to hire women they
wouldn't be able to just pull ethnic
minority men out of the diversity pool
they have to hire women and they would
also have to hire ethnic minority people
I didn't write it as if we want to make
a law I just said we want this concept
to be discussed more in depth and even
that didn't pass one of the most
powerful administrators in the directors
guild told a really close friend of mine
if the guild had a blacklist Maria dice
would be on it
this was the spring of 1979 which was
the Pleistocene age when dinosaurs were
still roaming in Hollywood and I mean
that literally and metaphorically at the
same time I came here from New York and
was invited to a meeting a large meeting
with a lot of women we said are you
working are you working are you working
and everyone said no we all met every
Saturday morning in my dining room with
all this data on the table some of these
piles were this big and it took a year
for us to finally come to the number of
how many women were working and how many
women weren't working and the number
that became clear was that of all the
assignments in both television and
motion pictures one-half of 1% of all
those jobs were going to women it did
come up we'll what's gonna happen you
know we can maybe we'll never work again
and so then we realized what do we have
to lose we're not working now
between 1979 or 80 and 1995 the
statistics jumped from one half of 1% to
16% in television they never they never
went that high on film they only went up
to 3% or 5% in fact that's where they
are right now now if those statistics
kept going up at that rate by now we
should be having about between 30 and 35
percent of all television jobs should be
given to women but that is not happening
in fact the statistics plateaued out
after 1995 and started to go backwards
which means that things have not
improved in the past 20 years how is
that possible the first director of any
narrative film was a woman Alice qiblah
Shaye so when people tell you you
shouldn't be directing because you're a
woman what I had been observing on Law &
Order hundreds of hundreds of hours I
observed and they would never ever give
me a job
and I asked why is it that women can't
get jobs I directed two feature films
why couldn't I get an episode of
television and they said it's a Gordian
knot it's just a conundrum we've all
fought for it we've all talked about it
and we just don't think anything can be
done about it
when movies didn't make money they said
well we tried a woman and it didn't work
out
imagine if they tried that with one guy
we tried a guy that didn't work so now
we're gonna go to what aliens
the women aren't making as much money so
they're the first people dropped off the
agents slate so if you don't have an
agent you don't the job clearly if
people still think we can't make money
you know we have to talk about things
that you know how much money Fifty
Shades did how much money frozen did and
Catherine Hardwicke turned the young
adult genre into a lucrative genre I'm
Catherine Hardwicke and I directed
Twilight losers and nobody knew that it
would be as big as it would be because
we were told why a book for girls like
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants that's
gonna max out it like 28 million dollars
that's all this movie will ever make
there's not a big enough audience for it
so they kept cutting the action
sequences down cut it down cut it down
cut the visual effects down so we could
make it for the budget they wanted to
make and then of course opening weekend
we made you know four hundred million
dollars
can we stop being surprised would it be
okay to stop being surprised it's like
when you hear you know a black person
speak and you say you so articulate
that's how insulting it is you can't
keep saying to us why well you can make
movies that originally successful I use
and say after Twilight people were
excited about divergent people were
excited about Hunger Games in fact even
people were inspired to write this books
probably with the success of Twilight so
I think it's shown that there is a
desire that there is an audience that if
you see a brave you know badass girl out
there that people woke up season me
disappointing that even though you know
a female director directed the first
Twilight did the whole cast that the
whole look yeah one of the other
Twilight's for The Hunger Games or
divergent they're all writ books written
by women starring a woman melt
has been directed by women we're having
a huge argument right now if women can
direct these big pictures of course they
can in the world of food budget mother
and desimilus there hasn't really been a
woman so there was pressure of that one
woman who's gonna all guide us there I
made a movie punish a war zone directors
have to have a vision and they have to
stick with that you can't be wishy-washy
about things you have to be decisive
I've actually had executives say things
to me like oh we're never hiring her and
she cannot make a decision if her life
depended on it
so that gave me a message of if you
soft-spoken and you trying to get along
with everybody that's not what they want
in a director yet at the same time I
remember precisely a development
executive saying to me we really want
the Punisher in a muscled out car flying
into a house and me saying absolutely
not that was me being difficult and this
is another one of those code words we're
like okay how exactly would you like me
to be decisive and stick to my vision
and be strong about what I want and yet
not upset anybody please give me the
secret to that it's a fair fair
situation I see this in film schools
where you know girls will direct the
scene and then one of the guys would say
well I don't think that's gonna work and
you will see that she will not quite
know how directed she would say well I
still want to do it this way and he will
go on and say I bet it doesn't make
sense when she then becomes stronger you
were here the whispers of [ __ ] going
through the whole room I've been the
first woman to direct on TV shows and I
found there were people who really
couldn't look at a woman AI and take
orders from a woman
now there's other ways of being a
director because let's face it there all
kinds shapes and sizes of male director
I ended up now sponsoring the largest
amount of research ever done on gender
in media covering over a 20 year span
and the results are appalling for every
one female character there are three
male characters the crowd seems there's
only 17% female characters which is
pretty horrifying we found that if
there's a female director or writer the
percentage of female characters on
screen goes up 10% so it has an impact
on what we see on screen
the reason I've focused on what happens
in front of the camera is because I feel
that we're training people from the very
beginning from when they're a little
toddler to see women as less important
and less competent we're not seeing
women in leadership positions so
therefore we're not seeing it in real
life one interesting example is that we
studied the occupations of all female
characters in film and TV and on TV
there are so many female forensic
scientists how'd you find her wheels
because of CSI and there says that
colleges are scrambling to keep up with
the number of women who want to study
forensic science because they've seen it
right and they say hey that looks great
I could do that
well we're not seeing women directing
films we're also not seeing female
directors on screen we're just not
seeing enough role models that would
make you say I could be that so it's a
huge huge problem and and that's why our
motto is if they see it they can be it
because you have to see it I was
president of the Directors Guild and the
only so far female president of the
Directors Guild in its many years of
being in exist
so what happened is I got tapped a
former president and says you know
you're gonna be President one day so I
said well you know I should run now then
they said oh you know so-and-so is older
than you we shall let him be present
first so why don't you step aside we'll
let him be present for us and then four
years later Oh so-and-so should run and
you should step aside I mean they told
me things like oh you're too young to be
present and then I said well how old
were you and you were president and they
were younger than I was at the time when
they said that they said well you have
to learn to play golf
got to schmooze with us in the bar
talking about sports and all this stuff
I found out later these are the kinds of
things that in corporations they tell
women I mean I really wondered about
this I was at a panel that was a joint
directors guild and writers guild there
was a lot of show runners in the
audience and the conversation got around
to how many times somebody would say oh
ya know we had we had a woman on our
staff we know we had a woman director
some bizarre reason when we're half the
population this idea that when you have
one or two you you're done you've done
your job I can vouch for the fact that
there are over 1,200 trained women
directors professional experienced women
directors directors guild members who
are not working and every year that goes
by that they're not working their
careers are dinged by the fact that
they're not working
when you dig into the pool of women
directors
it's a very shallow pool the most of the
women in that pool are movie stars or
the daughters of movie moguls or
producers or something you're for the
most part not going for women who have
been through film school and made
award-winning films and so forth that
those women get forgotten their names
don't appear on any list that that
producers can see they don't have any
way of knowing who those women are or
how they can access them and the
Directors Guild does this terrible thing
of maintaining this diversity list you
have to have directed within the last 18
months to be on this list so when a
production company a producer a
showrunner wants to hire a woman
director of any ethnicity they call the
DGA and they get this list and they get
the same list over and over again
they're about 27 women who are directing
over and over and over again so if the
producer is call the agents for those
women and they find they're all booked
up which they are because they're
getting all the work then they move on
to men because there's no other list to
pull from and those are lucrative
glamorous good jobs the DGA diversity
task force is a very important
organization within the guild now the
diversity task force is made up of DGA
directors and they are there to oversee
compliance of the DGA studio diversity
agreements and they're also actively
seeking open assignments on TV shows at
those same studios you can imagine what
an incredible conflict of interest this
is it's like having a police force that
you're asking to go and police a
corporation where they're also employed
but those women in that little pool
don't want any women to come in it's
like the economy of scarcity in fact a
young woman director went up to one
highly employed women directors in
television and asked her if she would
give her a hand getting into TV
directing she said why would I do that
for you you'll only be competing for
jobs against me
as soon as I made Twilight I would have
thought it would be a lot easier cuz I
could prove that I made four hundred
million dollars for a studio on a on a
thirty-seven million dollar budget and
it spawned a huge franchise and all the
other franchise is similar to it but it
was not easy for me after that in fact
it was just as difficult and my next
maybe I got paid less I'm in a situation
right now where I've written a
screenplay that a significant producer
wants to produce and a significant actor
wants to star in women who are known as
the foremost feminists in Hollywood as
producers and their belief system is
that they cannot get a movie made with a
woman director attached that's their
belief system I've spent every single
day of these last two and a half years
solely full-time dedicated to this
project this is the movie that I was put
on the planet to direct what do i do
what do i do do I say do I allow my
moral outrage to bubble up and say how
dare you or do I say this has been a
thirty-year struggle and do I take
advantage of this opportunity to maybe
have a really high profile movie made
that I would have written and that I
would produce but I won't direct someone
else will direct it is so outrageous now
to hear this stuff still going on to
hear that people still say we won't want
a woman we can't hire a woman a woman
couldn't do this I'm still hearing it
and I was president of the DGA
doesn't matter what you do because I
happen to be one of those directors I
did all the steps I did the guy's movies
I did the movie that wasn't a chick
flick and I was nominated for an Oscar
and I had to follow up feature that one
of what
we work hard you achieve your things you
pay your dues and you go up but when you
keep hitting balls when you shouldn't be
hitting balls it all makes no sense to
you anymore in the process of this I've
lost myself and I'm just like right now
trying to find it again like Who am I
who was I when I got here 20 if I could
go back I would never go into film
business I I would have done many many
other things you know this is actually
gonna make me cry because you know don't
don't film that
it's heartbreaking if I would meet
another 20 year old I would say run turn
around go into any other industry there
are a group of us who are basically
putting our names out there risking the
possibility of getting blacklisted and
never working again because we want to
change things for the next generation
because I want to change things for my
nine-year-old daughter and her friends
because because I don't want to see this
happen again to anybody
there's been silence for the last 20
years there's not silence anymore it's
amazing anyone who makes noise that's
that you know they they don't they do it
they have 13% of the jobs to lose and
that's brave to go up and say I'm sorry
I'm not just interested in myself I'm
interested in the other women who are
standing on either side of me some men
and women feel it isn't going to change
because some people feel it's almost
biological which if you were out there
scrambling in the dirt and trying to
kill a squirrel to eat it it would make
a difference who could run faster throw
a spear farther that would all make a
difference we don't live in that world
anymore and we've even the playing field
so the question is do we have enough
inner virtue to do the right thing or
does this have to be a war where a 51
percent of population
battles to get equal status why has not
one studio come forward and said that
not one network not one production
company has come forward and said we
cannot hear it anymore these stats are
horrible we were put in a volunteer
holder they're waiting until the
government doesn't and trust me we are
pushing for that it's not like we're not
pushing on all ends the simple truth is
the only thing that's going to change is
to hire women just hire us we're really
good I think people are now really
catching on and I feel like there's a
momentum building
to make a difference the only way it's
really going to change is if people just
like make a concerted effort people with
money and power which is studio execs
and a lot of them are women if they say
we are gonna have 50% women let's just
go for parody the public has to get
invested because here is why it does
matter it does matter who tells the
stories the reason you have you know
only size zero
you know girls who starve themselves to
death or you have 12 year olds and
certain outfits
everything is sexualized that's because
you don't have us behind the camera so
the public should get invested it make
it very simple I say don't worry about
making more movies starring a female
character if you do great cast me but
let's say the network makes a decision
we're gonna hire half women or take them
on as interns or apprentices whatever I
think we will be able to make this
change happen that it's going to
snowball it if we added female
characters it's great we have been over
the past 20 years we'll achieve parity
in 700 years so it's gonna be more like
seven if I have it if you do it if I can
somehow get my old self bag and and
overcome this and say look I'm just
gonna have to be back to before this
happened and like be the person I was
when I got here maybe I'll write another
film I have a disease I need to tell
stories because I am a director I am a
director this is what I do don't listen
to what they say that you're not good
enough or you can't do it or you're
incompetent or you're indecisive it's
all a lie make your voice heard that
you're mad as hell and you're not going
to take it anymore you can't take it
anymore or you won't have a career
you